recurrence relations happen a lot where
you have powers of X high powers of X in
the integrand but they also happen a lot
with trig functions so I'm going to get
you to try what yourself the example of
like you don't have a go where he is yes
and just before you do I try it out just
in case I the treatment is quite a lot
hotter which is why I I did this one
first and I left trick until afterwards
but just because you can't see I mean
you deranged my plots are looking for a
product right looking for a product
surfer is this whenever it's hard to see
a oh and add tracks on you know unknown
value you stick in a constant right so
if I would have asked you to do this and
I told you okay let's do this by part
right clearly you need to break this up
into a part of some kind right but you
don't have any options as to what the
product is going to be you've got sine
times sine times sine so what might be a
useful product probably sine and sine
squared okay there's not really other
alternatives if we broke up what it's I
cubed you're doing the same question if
you did sine squared inside it's the
same thing you couldn't break that in
what minus cos squared I think but it
wouldn't make anything easier because
you should do about the same power which
one function okay so that's how it would
look with a three what look like with it
first
should we give this a go I've seen quite
a few you've got no right well done if
you're struggling that's okay recurrence
relations are hard
all right in some ways and some of
you've noticed this already these are
kind of the hardest thing within the
integration topic they can really bend
your brain around let's have a go he's
like I am okay so I'm going to rephrase
that just like I did here as a product
and then I can choose my you and my DV
and then off I go okay so I'm gonna
write this as the integral of sine now
if I've got sign on as one factor right
how many signs do I have left n minus 1
right so I'll have sine n minus 1 X then
okay they you have to be very cautious
you are chain rule happening here it's a
bit easy to forget because um you don't
know what the power of sine is but stick
with it okay so I'm going to select my
you and my DV now
so here's my grid right what are some
last traces if we're gonna be
differentiating this thing right we want
it to be the one which is going to make
things a bit easier for us and the
problems going to get simpler okay so
which ought I to choose maybe I should
freeze it the other way I'm going to be
integrating this one right so I want
something that when I get over here it
doesn't make things worse for them right
probably integrating this is going to be
more of a hassle right so that's why I'm
gonna choose this is you okay sine n
minus one yep okay now because it's
chain rule because it's chain rule you
have to do two things you've got to do
that outside and you've got do the
inside all right so I'll do the inside
it's just sign isn't it it's a bit hard
to see if it's their brackets or
anything but the rumor sign is cause
good now you do the outside so the power
comes down I supposed to say oh it's a
cause of the coefficient I'll slap it
out the front and the power reduces by
one now some of you have thrown at this
you think foon have I done something
wrong now that's a that's a fair thought
to have okay however just consider the
alternative suppose if I had put this
here would it not be measurably worse if
I did that and then had to integrate
okay so it doesn't look like it's ideal
but let me see if I could work with it
all right what's my DV DX its side okay
so that gives me a V of negative cos
right okay good I've made all my
selections I've put my pieces together
let's integrate
I'm gonna get you V so it gives me this
negative cos sign to that power okay and
then I'm going across here right now
this does look quite bad you're going
was a double negative isn't there so I'm
gonna go fuss that n minus one is just
the closet so I'll slap that now the
front and then what you have inside the
integrand right is cos squared
sign and - - what about that bracket
sign her mayor's 2x with respect to X
and that looks like an awful mess okay
but it's not as bad as it looks right
because cause where of course we don't
want that course where we can
interchange it for something a lot more
useful to us right namely 1 minus sine
squared right so keep this guy at the
front here plus n minus 1 lots off okay
now this is 1 minus sine squared I'm
going to do the expansion in one go okay
your Zed one you can hurdle it so I've
got one lot of this which will be this
okay minus sine squared lots of this
okay when you have sine squared and
you're both side and minus 2x what
happens to the powers the powers will
add right that plus 2 and that n minus 2
will exactly cancel right so you'll get
this okay right now at this point
because we're trying to work toward a
recurrence relationship right because I
can now see that these are in the form
of one kind of my right I can start to
make some substitutions you write this
guy at the front he's kind of well he's
already integrated so we don't need to
worry about you okay but I am n minus
one lot off okay two hours the integral
what's this in terms of buying this is i
n minus two is it that's in now I could
do brackets again you know here and have
my I in here as you can see but it's in
my interest to actually stick that out
over here separately because I want to
make I am the subject right so I'm gonna
have to kick him over the other side
eventually I might as well get about a
brackets there so I've got my ends or
one I ate over there I've got n minus
one wait hold on that's really a - I
shouldn't yes no one picked it up lazy
ah when I add this to both sides okay
I'm gonna add n minus 1 by n where that
sounds confusing it might have some lots
of that the
over to the other side okay this
negative 1 will cancel with this one
right so I'll just be left with n of I
am and I'll always finish now just tidy
up Plus this ok I just what I am on
expand someone divides through I suppose
you could draw an enormous fraction like
that most people don't because it's long
and awkward if you don't need to so I'm
just going to slap that there and here
I'm going to have n minus 1 on all right
sir
does that look good does it make sense
is it coherent I think so all right as
long as you differentiate everything
probably it does look a little unusual
because when you're going from I ed you
skip one in the previous never we looked
at you got by n minus one that's what it
made sense one tells you the next one
tells you the next one bit like
induction if you like but this one you
skip to and it's to do with the nature
of these trig derivatives here and that
that it - - okay that's where it comes
from
okay so really quickly I'd like you to
see if you can use this recurrence
relationship relation to evaluate by
four can you do it what would you get at
the end have a go I'll give you a couple
of minutes and once you give that
light-skinned what happens let's try it
okay now I've already provided the first
line for you okay so the question will
tend to be phrased to you like this just
evaluate that sometimes part part why
middle part a might be show that this is
the recurrence relation so sign in to
the X sine log to the end X sorry okay
so once you do that you can start using
it okay so there's my I - because I've
dropped down there's my n minus two so
once I see that again I use the
recurrence relation again that's the
point of it being your recurrence
relation so you've got this at the front
which is already been integrated what's
gonna come next what's gonna be in here
well you look to this and you're
sticking in twos instead of fours right
so you're gonna get minus one on to you
this is going to be how many sides we're
gonna have just the one what's gonna
happen on the edge here you're gonna
have Plus uh-huh I know what's that look
right yeah now that might seem strange
to you okay but just remember we've
defined I thought in a way that was
competing to us right is our definition
for I consistent with a value of M being
zero and the answer is yes it is right
because this this is the integral that I
know right remember the point of going
through this process is you need to get
my parts you need to get your pots until
you get down to something you can just
regularly integrate right going to grab
my pot well I know what it's just sine X
to the power of 9 which of course is
just round right and I think we could
integrate that okay so at this point now
I'm gonna get rid of all of my lines
which means I also need to include a
constant expression and I can tiny this
thing up I've got my closed side cubes
there what are we gonna have here
actually I can take that half out code
on what I do that that's 3/8 that'll
give you one of these and once I don't
we said it was the integral of 1 right
which is X okay and of course I just
need to tidy up my own my coefficients
buts that look okay does that make sense
now just just pause and reflect on that
for a second okay admittedly admittedly
this took some work just took some
serious work okay but once we got to
this which your start to recognize look
at the number lines from here to here
right and in previous time you would've
looked at this it's just an it's all you
can't do anything with
we is too powerful are you crazy right
but recurrence relations just sort of
make mincemeat of this kind of problem
okay